leonie frage inwieweit hat sich dein
leben durch diesen videobeitrag
verändert komplett also ohne den
videobeitrag hätte ich nicht an meinem
teilnehmen können und demzufolge welchen
eine geschlossene psychiatrie gekommen
jetzt den titel gesehen und ich habe
heute einen ganz besonderen gast ohne
großes drumherum reden begrüße ich den
neben mir leute adhs luca könnte so
sagen
doch schon ist heute bei mir zu gast du
bist eigentlich relativ bekannt in fast
ganz deutschland mittlerweile für einen
ihm was vor vier jahren entstanden ist
er vor zehn jahren der für alle die sie
jetzt fragen jetzt nix anfangen
aber jetzt wird eingeblendet da hat mich
voller 1 meter 50 genauso wie heute kann
ich das nicht natürlich auch das ganze
ein bisschen vergessenheit geraten und
dann habe ich luca vor ein paar tagen
auf tik tok gesät habe ich eingestehen
wir möchten gerne dabei so ein interview
und ihren fragen gestellt 90 tagen
verfahren mit dem verein oder oh ja ok
wärs fall kommt etwas von mir wie waren
die ganze geschichte dahinter kannst du
das noch mal kurz zusammengefasst was
machst du das gerät die ganze geschichte
war im grunde genommen folgende ich
hatte mit meinem siebten lebensjahr
gerade da ist diagnostiziert bekommen
und den kindergarten alter oder auch
relativ schnell medikamentös eingestellt
auch ritalin die los wurde auch immer
gesteigert über die jahre irgendwann war
es halt so weit dass die pillen nicht
mehr wirklich etwas gebracht haben und
meine eltern waren generell die ganze
zeit seitdem er nicht so ganz konform
damit naja mit minderjährigen ab
vitamine
was wird er den ist rein zu ballern und
dann haben sie nach alternativen gesucht
nachdem halt der dritte oder vierte
schule wechseln dann schon stattgefunden
hat um die schule hat wirklich gesagt
hat okay entweder mehr tabletten oder
psychiatrie
dann sind wir auch das projekt via nova
gestoßen
denn das war dieses eine projekt worüber
die reportage ging und dieses ein
projekt das jahr davor zum ersten mal
stattgefunden da gab es schon ein
bericht darüber eine reportage wird
dadurch dass meine mutter darauf
aufmerksam geworden und dann wollte sie
mich da unbedingt rein haben und das
problem war allerdings dass das
jugendamt das nicht finanzieren wollte
ok demzufolge haben wir die reportage
benutzt war sie um das jugendamt unter
druck zu setzen damit sie dass diese
maßnahme bezahlen ja da war ich dann
acht wochen mit sechs anderen adhs lang
und generell schwer erziehbaren kindern
und wir mussten halt ohne strom ohne
fließend wasser ohne zucker ohne
sämtliche sag ich jetzt mal schädlichen
lebensmittel da auf der alm zurecht
kommen wir ab so ist es zu allen
gekommen und danach war ich drei jahre
noch bei einem der betreuer anwesend und
abzeichen weil gelernt selbst zu
reflektieren sehr viel an mir selber zu
arbeiten und bin danach wieder ganz
normal zur schule gehen das ist so das
ganze in aller schärfe
ok alles klappte in diesem video beitrag
ist ja dann auch quasi dieses dass das
niemand starten was letzten endes so
ultra kraft die runde gemacht hat wie
war das denn so wie du bist glaube ich
der die erste person die ich treffe die
das tatsächlich in ihrem leben erlebt
hat wie ist das wenn man das so sagen
kann dass man so als nicht einmal mit so
einem moment groß wird in deutschland
das er vor zehn jahren passierte meinte
zu mir weil landes die runde gemacht
weil man derzeit und wohl auch wirklich
gesehen haben also damals als die
reportage rauskam haben wir das
natürlich schon viele leute gesehen
gerade ein schüler wurde ich auch
ja auch dann noch darauf angesprochen
aber damals war der hype noch nicht so
groß der richtig große halb kamen zum
ersten mal auf die youtube
da habe ich dann gemerkt dass die ersten
standen sind es war 2016/2017 war das so
youtube charaktere sind youtube er
genommen aber das okay
genau das war das war auch das was ich
gesehen habe wie viele freunde dazu
besteht am main von die gibt's nicht
youtube kaffeegenuss und ein best of von
alles und ich habe damals das total
gefeiert haben wir so eine geile weil
das ding war in der reportage habe ich
ja sag ich jetzt mal sehr sehr sehr
krass überspitzt gehandelt werden das
hat mich von körpers gemacht viele leute
sagen ja immer noch die reportage war
fake oder was weiß ich nicht weil die
reportage manche scripted aber ich habe
extrem viel show in dieser reportage
gemacht weil ich entertain wollte ok
also dieser aus wasser zum beispiel auch
mit der unterschrift der wahl war
komplett selber kompletten aber sonst
hast du gesagt okay ich will auch
bewusst bisschen provokant sein laut
sein jahr weil einfach ich unterhaltung
bieten wollte für mich war sage ich
jetzt mache kamera drauf sondern denn
willst du den leuten etwas bieten
ich wollte halt entertainer welche art
von aufmerksamkeit bekommt man wenn man
so in so youtube compilation ist in
deutschen - irgendwas dran ist bei
dieser deutschen münchen ist in den
letzten ein zwei mal richtig groß
geworden welche aufmerksamkeit ist das
und irgendwie war das in der schulzeit
früher dass das ist das ding so die
ministerin
durchgestartet sind halt erst nachdem
ich als wirklich aus der schule raus kam
näher und ort sah ich mal wenn ich dann
noch zur em habe ich die leute die
komplett darauf angesprochen
mittlerweile ist natürlich so dadurch
dass ich ja auch in seiner musikalischen
hintergrund habe ich bin eine beatbox
szene relativ groß und da sage ich jetzt
einfach mal so du wirst sehr oft noch
auf dieses nur herunter seid jetzt mal
definiert das ist ja der typ mit 1 mehr
da ist der das ist er also die
aufmerksamkeit bekommt ist da kommen wir
das ist der jagd okay ich hatte mir
vorgestellt dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen sehr negativ sein kann also ich
hab dann zum beispiel an den kämpfen
noch den mann wie die tore mit jungen
muss ja ja ich war angetan und spielen
durch der das war ja auch gestellt von
ihm das hat er bewusst gerade auch in
nur noch der audi wurde kann fertig
gemacht dafür
ich glaube schon dass viele leute halt
stark darauf reduzieren da auch sehr
negativer auch natürlich natürlich nicht
alles war auch mit dabei aber das weiß
nicht nur leser also weniger von dem
leben halt mehr von meinem verhalten in
der schule also dass das nie war da
wenig ausschlaggebend
ich halte generell in der schule schon
seid ihr auch nach der einem noch guten
schulabschluss gemacht da war ich kein
muster schön wie du warst ich war
abgedreht
sie habe immer meine burschen zu einem
dazu gesagt und sage ich mal so die
opferrolle
die hatte ich auch vor der reportage
schon ich war zehn jahre lang wurde ich
gemobbt ok außenseiter und psycho und
dass ich nicht was dort als nur das bild
wurde was ich allerdings dazu sagen muss
nicht brav krass drauf also total
provokant total übergriffig und ich kann
es halt zu gewissem maße einfach
nachvollziehen dass das die leute mit
mir nichts anfangen kann
dieses herunter definieren auf das
nehmen war bei mir nicht so krass zucker
also wie gesagt aber ich war es halt mit
dem mobilen einfach auch schon gewohnt
demzufolge hat erklärte also solch eine
frage die die stellen muss wird und sich
auch selbst schon geahnt dass sie kommen
wird maxi heute möchte gerne wissen wie
es denn war von der kante runterzufallen
schmerzhaft
klar ist die frage gestellt werden
mussten wir einfach mal die die story
von der 1150 hohen kante kann ich noch
mal raus hauen gehabt das ding war ich
war auf meinem ich habe meinen
geburtstag auf der alm verbracht und es
gab einen jungen mit dem ich schon am
anfang der einwand einander gehoben
geraten denn der typ is peggy mit dem
hatte beispiel auf kriegsfuß und wir
anhalt weil er total die provokanten
persönlichkeit und ich habe an meinem
geburtstag gerade oben geschilderten
dachboden angeboten
es gab halt so sagt man bereich du musst
halt in den unteren bereich runter über
eine leiter gehört und er irgendwas zu
mir gesagt ich kann nicht mehr drauf und
dran genau erinnern was es war mit
hunden an der leiter gestand und ich bin
halb oben zu leiter gange und er meinte
die dazu provozieren ich habe provoziert
und sagst du so ein tag kommt man mal an
geburtstage cetera und hat
wahrscheinlich auch berühmten blöden
spruch gemacht und er in dem moment
zieht an derlei traten und das war s
wahrheit locker so ein abschlag von 1
meter 50
also vielleicht auch mehr aber ich bin
da halt mit der leiter voran auf den
schädel von den paten holz
die alsweder 50 uhr panther die tat
verdammt eben weil es an meinem
geburtstag war nicht das war der einzige
tag auf der einen kontakt zu deinen
eltern haben suchst du sonst gern hallo
briefkontakt er selbst er war extrem
beschränkt ballerei ablenkung
ab dem moment weiß sowieso mit dem
absoluten krieg kriegsfuß und dann hatte
der hype zahnschmerzen gehabt da ist in
allen anderen feuer und dann habe ich
halt sprüche geklopft und als die
betreuerin mich deswegen angemahnt
gianni möchte wissen ob du oft darauf
angesprochen wird und ob das immer noch
passiert ist möglicherweise verletzt
wird sogar zugenommen
da will aktiv ist mit der mit der 1
meter 50 ehrenkarte oder mit dem
generell auch das aria ist nämlich
ansprechen
das ganze ding einfach so ja also sage
ich jetzt mal so dadurch dass ich auch
tik tok jetzt so bekannt geworden bin
habe ich auch wieder das coming-out
video gemacht und auch hier ich bin der
typ der einfach weil ich auch das bild
vermitteln wollte so verändern sich über
zehn jahre
natürlich sprechen mich viele leute
darauf an also ich werde auch wenn ich
beispielsweise in göttingen ich gewohnt
habe es werten gegangen bin ich
eigentlich fast jedes mal habe ich die
clemens guter caddie ist gefragt bist du
der typ bist du der typen also ich werde
ständig darauf angesprochen
ich finde es auch nicht schlimm wenn man
mich darauf ansprechen das sage ich
jetzt mal eine respektvolle wenn wir
jetzt einfach hinterher
50 jahren tricks in lünen blick und mehr
dann aber auch nicht hände 712 frank
hättest du gerne dass das video
aufgenommen wird bzw dass das keiner
mehr kennt das video ist aber noch
online auf youtube dazu muss auch noch
action kommen leute würdest du das jetzt
unternehmen wollen als meint das ist
jetzt seine lebensgeschichte so bis zum
heutigen punkt soll das auch weiter so
sein oder wird so werdet ihr das jetzt
abgeschlossen ist wie willst du sein
ich würde es nicht unternehmen ich würde
gern die werbeeinnahmen haben aber
ansonsten was ist tatsächlich ganz da
jetzt mal was ich unterstützen würde
werden den fokus jetzt noch mal auf mich
zukommen würde und sagen würde haye wir
drehen jetzt nochmal eine episode genau
quasi ein update das ganz normal weiß
wie in irgendeiner von focus dass ihr
seht dann machen sie dann wichtiger das
muss cook ist es eigentlich mache
superschurke käufer kasten social media
so selbstverständlich ist auch alles
haben und verlegt deutschland ein
youtube kanal
du hast tik tok kanal auch auf dem du
auch sehr gut abgeht ist alles blinkt
leute und ja ich kann ich nur empfehlen
bei zuschauern super schuldigkeit noch
magst du geld fürs mitmachen bei der
portale bekommen das ist auch alles
wir haben ganz wenig bekommen
dabei hatte sie haben wir haben ein
bisschen was bekommen ja aber das war
nicht mal sage ich jetzt mal die ganzen
kosten gedeckt die für das mal meiner
ausrüstung für die einen hat er ja ja
also das war minimal also wie gesagt die
einmal mehr eine funktion deshalb das
projekt von der von der im jugendamt
finanziert wird als das
irgendwie jeder mit irgendwie groß plus
ausgegangen niederfeld hast du noch
kontakt zu den nicht geschubst hat
kannst du bei dem schon mal angedeutet
dass also mit perry habe ich keinen
kontakt aber ich habe mit zwei leuten
die auf der einmal habe ich noch kontakt
und zwar einmal pascal das war der etwas
korpulentere der stadt wo auch noch
mainz weit legendär ist das alles her
gekommen ist drei worte worte der mit
dem habe ich noch kontakt
der war auch länger als ich bei rüdiger
noch also rüdiger ist ja der betreuer
der mich dann aufgenommen hat die drei
jahre und mit dem ältesten von der hat
sich auch zwischenzeitlich machen mit
bei mir gemeldet auch an die anderen vor
allem wenn ihr das hier seht meldet euch
bei mir florian gibt hier ein ganz gutes
stichwort und zwar mit kasimir etwas
kannst und sagt zu erzählen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ich kann
ich weiß nicht ob ich dazu wir erzählen
da okay okay ich kann einfach nur so
viel sagen aber das ist ja schon
allgemein weiß es ja auch dass er
irgendwas ist das wissen die leute ja da
ist was ich weiß wirklich ob ich
bestätigen fakt ist ich bin neugierig ok
inwieweit werde ich jetzt noch nicht ja
ja ja aber kommen wird sagen wir's
einfach mal so leonie frage inwiefern
hat sich dein leben durch diesen
videobeitrag verändert komplett stelle
mir vor wie es gelaufen ohne und wie es
jetzt mit gelaufen
naja also ohne den videobeitrag hätte
ich nicht teilnehmen können und
demzufolge welchen der geschlossenen
psychiatrie gekommen wäre dann
wahrscheinlich medikamentös extrem sag
ich jetzt mal höchstniveau eingestellt
worden und höchstwahrscheinlich welche
irgendwann schon wieder zur schule
gegangen aber halt wirklich nur mit
medikamentöser unterstützung und jetzt
wahrscheinlich irgendwann wirklich die
mentalität beibehalten okay wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie funktionieren wenn ich
irgendwann mal an dem schatten möchte
dann brauche ich dazu medikamentöse
unterstützung
wahrscheinlich wäre vieles anders
gelaufen sage ich jetzt mal aber ich bin
wie gesagt sehr froh dass es jetzt so
gelaufen ist wie es gelaufen ist weil
wie gesagt die alternative wäre nur
schön gewesen kraft also hat quasi auf
irgendeine art und weise auch keine
negativen konsequenzen hatte der
videobeitrag auf dein leben die
positiven für einen extrem nur einer die
diese 1 geschichte ermöglicht hat ja und
auch den kontakt zu den betreuer danach
über die jahre entstanden ist ja
verrückt wenn ich leute das ist wirklich
keiner geschichte wirklich dumme frage
aber egal
magst du dicke immer noch nicht
ich habe an sich nichts gegen dicke sag
ich's einfach immer so um die aussage
von damals zu erklären bis dato zu dem
zeitpunkt habe ich nicht eine einzige
positive erfahrung mit einem
übergewichtigen menschen also die bahn
zu mir immer extrem respektlos und waren
seit jetzt mal schlecht gelaunt
mittlerweile kann ich auch
nachvollziehen ich meine sei jetzt mal
als als kräftiger mensch hat es ja auch
schwer im leben mache ich auch extrem
viele negative erfahrungen mit menschen
und systemen zufolge glaube ich auch
sage ich jetzt mal ein bisschen vor
geprägt was die haben jetzt weise an
menschen ist und da ich generell ein
sehr sehr provokanter mensch war ich
meine ihr der clip aus der reportage wo
ich noch mal eine aussage gemacht hat
ich hatte damals so seien die impulse
die in meinem kopf entstanden sind
einfach kurzen putt zum mond raus
also du siehst können sie im kräftigen
management dann sofort geht der hat
deswegen möchte sagen gott also nee nee
nee so nicht das kommt halt schon drauf
an wie wie dieser menschheit auch auf
mich zu geht aber das problem ist halt
einfach dass ich damals halt nur
impulsiv gehandelt habe und irgendwann
wenn auch mir anspruch gedrückt wurde da
habe ich diesen spruch nicht akzeptiert
sondern dann wurde ich beleidigen und
das in dem falle leider auch sehr oft
persönlich was tut mir wirklich leid für
die für die menschen denen ich da in der
vergangenheit zu tun also wie gesagt ich
kann es folgen verstehen dass sich
ausgegrenzt wurde weil ich hatte er das
bloß war aber mittlerweile hat natürlich
auch diese meinung schon gestiftet sah
ich jetzt einfach mal ich hab einfach
sei jetzt einfach mal die
oberflächlichkeit die ich damals
vollkommen verinnerlicht hatte habe ich
nahezu weg
gibt es irgendetwas was du den leuten da
draußen sagen möchtest du irgendwas zu
korrigieren wie du von bisher falsch
wahrgenommen wurde ist oder irgendeine
botschaft die den leuten mitgehen würde
sondern was ich einfach generell den
leuten einfach immer mitgeben möchte ist
hauptsache ich jetzt mal verständnis für
menschen mit sag ich jetzt mal solchen
psychischen störungen wie wie ich jetzt
halt hatte mit adhs aber nicht nur adhs
es geht auch um borderline es geht auch
um depressionen sind also es gibt so
viele psychische seite zerstörungen die
einfach von der gesellschaft einerseits
durch mangelhafte kommunikation nicht
richtig sei jetzt mal vermittelt werden
wie das ist ja und da muss ich muss ich
einfach wirklich appellieren so grenzt
solche leute nicht aus weil das einzige
was ich damals halt auch wollte war
einfach dazu gehören die leute irgendwie
dazu gehören aber hab bis zeit immer auf
den falschen weg gemacht deswegen also
was ich den leuten noch mitgeben kann es
habt geduld mit diesen menschen und vor
allem stempeln sie nicht sofort ab als
wenn es psychisch oder hat was ich oder
der der chemie und der kann irgendwie
was ich nicht mag ja weil ich glaube ich
bin würde ich jetzt mal sagen das beste
beispiel dafür dass man eben nicht vor
christi nähert ist wenn man eine solche
erkrankung hat wäre ich bin sowieso sei
einfach mal der meinung wenn man etwas
schaffen will dann kann man das auch ich
bin kein freund von den von der aussage
ja das kann ich nicht so ja da würde ich
halt einfach sagen akzeptiert die leute
reflektiert wenn wir solche sag jetzt
mal probleme habt wie ich sie hatte
schaut dass ihr einen weg findet damit
umzugehen der für euch halt das passende
ist ob das mit medikamenten ist oder
ohne medikamente dass es komplett euch
überlassen schaut einfach wie ihr euer
leben wollt wie ihr euch euer leben
vorstellt und sage ich jetzt mal wie
viel ihr bereit seid dafür zu tun
schöne schluss denn dann würde ich sagen
hierüber über 140 und könnte einen kanal
abonnieren schreibt fragen die jetzt
noch ab in die kommentare ich habe da so
viel zu beantworten vielleicht bist du
auch ist in den kommentar unterwegs
ansonsten wird ihn wahrscheinlich zwei
tagen direktion kommen auf die folge bis
dahin sind wir raus und macht